welcome everyone I'm senior Provost Lori
weingartz and it's my pleasure to
welcome you all to the Carnegie Mellon
University's Dickson Prize award
presentation and lecture today we're
honored to have dr. Jennifer Doudna our
Dickson Prize in science recipient on
campus at Carnegie Mellon she'll be
giving her lecture entitled CRISPR
systems nature's toolkit for genome
editing in a short while but first some
thank yous are in order to Professor
Emeritus
guy berry and his colleagues on the
Dickson prize committee thank you for
making such an excellent choice in the
selection of dr. Doudna as this year's
honoree also thank you to dr. Aaron
Mitchell of our Biological Sciences
Department who brought dr. down his
candidacy to the table
dr. Mitchell who you will hear from
shortly as serving as our faculty host
for her visit I'd also like to take this
opportunity I believe to recognize dr.
Michael McQuaid is he with us today my
trustee I was hoping he could join us ah
there you are welcome he's joining us
and also I want to he's one of our port
of trustee members of our board of
trustees so welcome and also I want to
thank everyone else for joining us today
we have a standing-room-only crowd so
welcome everybody is one of Carnegie
Mellon's most important scientific
events of the year the Dickson Prize
lecture honors leaders in science for
their accomplishments and marks
important trends and New Directions of
scientific thought the Dickson Prize in
science at CMU is the sister award of
the Dickson Prize in medicine at the
University of Pittsburgh both awards
were established by dr. Joseph Dickson
who was a prominent Pittsburgh surgeon
and his wife Agnes Fisher Dickson with
this prize dr. and mrs. Dickson hoped to
bring as much prestige and honor as
possible to the two universities and to
the city of Pittsburgh Carnegie Mellon
has bestowed the Dixon prize on leading
scientist since 1970
and each year we've been able to bring
some of the country's most
forward-thinking scientists to our
Pittsburgh campus scientific fields have
changed dramatically over those forty
eight years through the Dixon prize CMU
has consistently held a front-row seat
during this area of era of
transformation which is a true honor for
our faculty for our students and the
entire university community the Dixon
prize is a wonderful opportunity for
Carnegie Mellon to recognize leaders in
diverse areas of science whose work has
made significant contributions we
especially consider the work of those
investigators whose research relates to
our complements programs at Carnegie
Mellon the Dixon Prize recipient where
you're honoring today dr. Jennifer
Doudna is here to give us a view into
her work and the question it poses both
for today and for the future dr. Doudna
is a professor at the University of
California at Berkeley in the department
of molecular and cell biology as well as
the department of chemistry and she's a
member of the Howard Hughes Medical
Institute and the Lawrence Berkeley
National Lab Doudna and her colleagues
rocked the research world in 2012 by
describing a new broadly applicable way
of editing the DNA of any organism using
an RNA guided protein found in bacteria
this discovery reduced the time and work
needed to edit genomic DNA this
technology called CRISPR Castine has
opened the floodgates of possibility for
human and non-human applications of gene
editing including assisting researchers
in the fight against serious chronic
diseases such as HIV sickle-cell disease
and muscular dystrophy a process that
used to take ten to fifteen highly
specialized scientists now enables one
person to make precise edits to DNA
strands potentially accelerating
discovery of treatments for these
genetic diseases from an economic and
scalability perspective many of these
edits have implications for
proving quality of life efficiency of
research processes and product life
cycles we've already seen advances in
crop in crop and livestock livestock
applications as a result of dr. Daoud
nose discoveries
dr. stoutness work is also at the center
of the genetic ethics debate as this
process could potentially be used to
create so-called designer babies while
we've not yet seen a person with an
edited genome as far as I know as the
process evolves and become simpler dr.
Doudna is leading the conversation on
how ethical boundaries should be drawn
this past summer her book co-authored
with Sam Sternberg a crack in creation
was published the book provides a
personal account of her research and
examines the societal and ethical
implications of gene editing like the
Dixon prize awardees before her doctor
Doudna is a highly renowned scholar and
scientist she was elected to the
National Academies of Sciences in 2002
and to the Institute of Medicine in 2010
she's also a foreign member of the Royal
Society and has received many additional
honors including the breakthrough prize
in life sciences the Heineken Prize for
biochemistry and biophysics the BBVA
foundation frontiers of knowledge award
and the Japan prize for original and
outstanding achievements in science and
technology again it is such a great
honor to have dr. Jennifer Doudna here
with us this afternoon to accept a
Dickson Prize in science for the year of
now I'd like to welcome dr. Mitchell to
the stage to say a bit more about dr.
Donna please join me well it is a
special honor to give my perspective on
the work of dr. Jennifer Doudna I've
come to know her work because it has
enabled numerous projects in my
laboratory because it's given me more
ideas for projects than I could ever
hope to pursue in my lifetime and
because I've given a course about genome
editing in which her studies are central
for the past two years from reading all
of her papers and thinking very deeply I
have learned something important dr.
Donna is among the most imaginative
insightful and accomplished scientists
of our time the goal of her research is
to elucidate the mechanisms by which RNA
mediates gene regulation this objective
may sound fairly narrow at first blush
until one realizes that RNA has a
central role in almost everything that a
cell does
so dr. Donna's objective in essence is
to use RNA as an entry point in order to
elucidate the mechanisms behind almost
everything that a cell does dr. Donna
has been recognized most recently for
her seminal contributions to the genome
editing field and CRISPR technology the
subject of her talk today her work
extends far beyond that though to the
understanding of the natural biology of
CRISPR systems the mechanistic roles of
micro RNAs in the regulate and
regulation and higher organisms and the
insidious devices that viruses use to
override our natural defenses so you can
see that dr. Doudna actually is well on
her way to understanding the mechanisms
behind just about everything that a cell
does dr. Daoud in his methodology draws
from many disciplines but she is
especially known for her work on
structural biology those papers of hers
are a distinct pleasure to read because
without exception they make very tight
connections between the structures that
she has discovered and the biological
activities of the molecules in question
she's also used the structural
information to engineer variant proteins
that do things more rapidly and with
higher fidelity than the versions that
Nature has provided us I learned the
most surprising and inspiring facet of
dr. Daoud in his pioneering work in
structural biology from a lovely
portrait of her that appeared in new
york times a few years ago she began her
work in this very technical and
specialized field as a postdoctoral
researcher with no formal training in
the area she chose the approach simply
because it was the best way to address
the questions that she found most
compelling and significant at the time
the inspiration that I hope we can all
take away from this is not for all of us
to go into structural biology and
especially not without much training but
to choose as dr. Doudna always does the
best tools to address the most
compelling and most significant
questions and now to present the 2017
Dixon prize award I asked dr. weingartz
to the podium again
[Applause]
[Music]
and please join me in welcoming dr.
donut to the stage as well
[Applause]
[Music]
dr. down on behalf of Carnegie Mellon
University I'm pleased to present you
with the 2017
Dixon prize and recognition of your
scientific contributions in the area of
biochemistry congratulations
[Applause]
No
good afternoon everyone it's an
incredibly exciting moment for me to be
here I am really just really touched and
honored to have this opportunity to
accept the Dixon prize and to visit with
all of you here at CMU and I want to say
in a special thank you to Laurie
Weingarten Aaron Mitchell Takei Barry
and his colleagues and and also to the
students that I met with today it's just
been a really fun day of talking about
science about innovation about how
discoveries come about and how they can
create the future really and take us in
directions that we could have never
anticipated and that's really the story
that I want to share with you today
because you know as you heard in that
very nice generous introduction I am
trained as a biochemist and I still
think of myself that way we've done a
lot of structural biology over the years
but fundamentally I got into science
because I really wanted to understand
how molecules work and I wanted to
understand something about the
underlying evolutionary basis at the
molecular level for life as we know it
currently how how it came to be this way
and I've addressed this by by you know
really studying different aspects of RNA
molecules and the way they control the
flow of genetic information in cells and
that that as I'll explain to you here
shortly that's really how I got into
working on CRISPR systems which are
bacterial adaptive immune systems
something that even you know ten years
ago or so just a handful of labs around
the world were investigating and I think
the story really starts with the
discovery of the structure of DNA when I
think about you know if we think about
gene editing certainly it begins with
understanding the the double helix of
DNA which was of course reported back in
the 1950s but this also is kind of the
interesting beginning of my own story in
science because I was given a copy of
James Watson's famous book the double
helix back when I was probably in middle
school and when I got that book
I read it and was kind of had my mind
blown by by understanding how scientists
could have an idea and do experiments to
figure out something even as complicated
and tiny as the structure of DNA and it
really kind of gave me the idea that
that was the kind of thing I wanted to
do with my life I wanted to spend my
life doing that kind of experimentation
I didn't know exactly what but I knew
that that was sort of very captivating
to me and so then I went off to I went
off to to college and I was actually a
chemistry major in college with a focus
on biochemistry and we were taught the
the central dogma of biology and my in
the one sort of you know it sort of
introductory biology course that I took
which is shown right here which is the
idea that cells encode genetic
information in DNA that's the importance
of understanding its structure and that
that information that's encoded is is
conveyed to the cell and is sort of
implemented through a process that
involves copying DNA into molecules of
RNA and then and then translating those
RNA molecules if they're messenger RNAs
mRNAs into proteins and that the
proteins do all of the interesting
things in the cell so you know when I
sort of grew up in science I thought
well DNA is really interesting because
it's the code and proteins are really
interesting because they're the the
actors but in the middle is this kind of
boring you know
throwaway copy of the genome called RNA
and I never paid much attention to it
but interestingly enough when I got into
graduate school I had the good fortune
to make my way to the lab of Jack
szostak and in the at the time he was a
he was actually a yeast geneticist he
was studying recombination of DNA but he
told me when I came to his lab as a
first-year graduate student he said well
actually I've gotten very interested in
the origin of life and I want to
understand how RNA molecules might have
been involved in the very early steps
that gave rise to life as we know it on
earth
and so that
really set the stage for what I've ended
up kind of thinking about in a way for
my whole career which is the functions
of RNA molecules themselves and as you
heard in the introduction from dr.
Mitchell I started my professional
career thinking about the molecular
structures of RNA and we were in those
days focused on catalytic RNA so RNA
molecules that can do interesting
chemical reactions in cells and and then
when I moved my laboratory so I started
my professional life at Yale University
as a assistant professor and then I was
recruited away to Berkeley eight years
later and when I moved to UC Berkeley I
really wanted to start studying the ways
that RNA molecules control the flow of
genetic information in cells and we we
were in those days working on very tiny
pieces of RNA called micro RNAs that are
made by animal and plant cells where
they perform roles in defending plants
in particular against viruses and in
animal cells and in humans in
controlling the timing and the levels of
proteins that are made in cells in all
sorts of different interesting pathways
and so we were as biochemists studying
how these very tiny micro rna's are made
and how they're able to act in
conjunction with proteins to control the
output of the genome and in an
interesting way that was actually what
got me into inter crispers because I was
sitting in my office at Berkeley one day
and it was probably around 2005 or 2006
or so and I got a call from a colleague
Gillian Banfield who's shown here and
and Jill is a member of our faculty in
the College of Natural Resources she
does work on bacteria but not in a an
experimental setting she actually works
in the environment so she collects soil
samples and looks at what kinds of
microbes are occupying those
environmental niches by doing deep
sequencing of the DNA that corresponds
to the genomes of those bugs and also of
course the kinds of viruses that they're
interacting with in their environment
and she called me up because she said
Jennifer I I I don't know you well but I
know that you work on RNA and I've made
a discovery in my lab that I think is it
will be interesting to you and so of
course I was interested in finding out
what that might be and we met up to to
discuss this and it turned out that she
had come across a number of examples of
very unusual DNA sequences in the
bacterial genomes of many of the
organisms that her lab was uncovering
and these were these had come to be
called crispers which stands for
clusters of regularly interspaced short
palindromic repeats say that five times
fast and but we call them crispers and
what these are is a pattern of DNA
sequences that are occurring in the
bacterial chromosome so this is a
circular bacterial chromosome here is
DNA and in at a particular location in
the chromosome is a if it has a CRISPR
it has a repeating sequence of DNA shown
by the black diamond that occurs over
and over and in between these repeats
are unique sequences of DNA that
initially didn't seem to match to
anything that had been identified at
that point so nobody knew really what
these were and it was a very unusual
kind of repetitive pattern of sequences
that scientists had started to to
uncover in various settings but had no
idea what they might be doing and the
reason these were started to be of
interest and interesting to jill was
that the previous year three
bioinformatics teams had published
papers that pointed out that in many of
these CRISPR arrays and bacterial
genomes there were sequences in these
these these what are called spacer
sequences between the repeats that
corresponded to DNA sequences from
viruses that infect these bacteria so it
was the first hint that these might
actually represent some kind of an
adaptive immune system in bugs some way
that bugs could acquire DNA sequences
from viruses and store them in these
arrays and then somehow possibly use
to protect cells from future viral
infection and what was intriguing about
these arrays was that they didn't occur
in isolation they were actually found in
close proximity to genes these were DNA
sequences that were known to encode
proteins that were CRISPR associated or
cast they were called cast genes and
nobody knew the functions of any of
those proteins but they had interesting
similarities to proteins that carry out
DNA repair DNA cutting DNA manipulations
in different ways so the hypothesis was
maybe these crispers are actually an
adaptive immune system in bacteria and
so from that very early conversation
with Jill Banfield I got intrigued and I
thought well this this would be amazing
if bacteria have some RNA based way of
protecting themselves from viruses and I
was hooked so I'm gonna tell you sort of
three aspects of the work that we've
been doing on these CRISPR systems over
the last decade or so I'm first going to
tell you about our work on an enzyme
called Kass 9 this is a protein that's
part of the CRISPR system that is a
programmable DNA cutter that means it's
an enzyme that can be programmed with
little pieces of RNA that come from the
CRISPR array to find and cut a
particular DNA sequence and by
understanding how this protein works it
was possible to harness it as a for a
very different purpose namely for gene
editing I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you
about that I'm gonna say a little bit
about how we think about approaching the
use of gene editing to cure genetic
disease and I'm gonna give you one
example of the work that we have going
on currently in the laboratory to think
about treating neurological disease with
with gene editing and finally I want to
say a few words at the end about what I
call responsible progress namely
thinking about how we ensure that gene
editing which is a very exciting but
also a very very powerful technology how
we ensure that it's used in a
responsible fashion going forward so so
first of all to tell you
about how we got into the studying this
particular protein cast line so this is
a cartoon that illustrates what is
currently understood or was understood
even a you know a few years ago about
CRISPR adaptive immune systems and
bacteria and so on what I'm showing you
in this cartoon is a segment of a
bacterial cell so here's the the
bacterial cell cell membrane and we've
got a viruses that are infecting this
cell and injecting their DNA into the
cell and when an infection like that
occurs the DNA goes in and it contains
the codes for the the program that's
necessary to make more viruses so it
quickly takes over the cells machinery
unless it's a bacterial cell it has a
CRISPR system and if it has a CRISPR
system then what the cell can do is to
detect that foreign DNA and integrate a
small piece of it into the CRISPR array
and it does that on one end of the array
so a little segment of DNA is inserted
it's flanked by copies of these repeat
elements so it's sort of marked in the
cell as part of this CRISPR array and
then the cell is able to make an RNA
copy of that array initially has a long
piece of RNA that's chopped into smaller
units each containing a sequence that
comes from a virus and those RNAs then
assemble with one or more of the cast
proteins to form an effector complex a
complex protein RNA that's able to
search the cell looking for a sequence
of DNA that matches the letters in the
RNA molecule and if a match is found
then the proteins in this complex are
able to cut up the DNA so it's a great
way that the cell can program this
protein to find and cut viral DNA that
it's been exposed to in the past and so
you know in the lab we actually when I
first started working on these systems
we started by working on this sort of
middle intermediate step which is si
speaks to my expertise thinking about
how these RNA molecules are made and how
they work but we we we quickly started
to investigate this downstream step here
namely interference and how the cell is
able to use these protein RNA complex
is to actually recognize and cut DNA and
over the years we've now actually worked
on all the aspects of this pathway but I
really want to focus on our work on this
sort of interference step so one of the
things to appreciate about CRISPR
systems and in biology is that you're in
bacteria is that they're highly diverse
and and this is a cartoon taken from a
review article that was published now
and two years ago in 2016 that showed
that you could divide these CRISPR
systems largely into two classes the top
class here are are sort of characterized
by having multiple proteins that come
together to form these effector
complexes and those were the ones that
we began investigating early on but
there's also this class down here called
class two that are distinct because they
each have a single large protein that is
responsible for protecting the cell from
viruses and sort of an RNA guided way
and that was not understood or early on
it was simply known genetically that
each of in bugs that had these types of
CRISPR systems if you made a genetic
knockout of these these large genes then
the cell lost its ability to defend
itself against viruses using the CRISPR
pathway so I I went to a conference in
in Puerto Rico in 2011 and I met a
colleague a Manuel sharpen TA who had
complementary expertise to my own she's
a medical microbiologist and in talking
with her at that conference we began
discussing a system that she had been
investigating in her own lab of a type
of bacteria that has one of these
so-called class two systems shown right
here that had this large gene called
Cass 9 that was known genetically to be
essential for CRISPR function in these
bugs but at the time nobody knew what
this protein encoded by Cass 9 miscast 9
protein what it actually did and so at
that meeting we decided to team up to
figure out the answer to this question
what is the function of Cass 9 how does
it work what does it do
and so his biochemist we
to purify this enzyme and test its
activity in a purified setting so we
could add crispr RNA to it we could add
DNA to it and start to ask can we get
can we observe any kind of chemical
reaction when we when we put these
molecules together and initially the
answer was no nothing was really working
until we realized that this is a system
that is actually operating through the
actions of and the guiding functions of
two separate pieces of RNA and so this
was the work of two talented scientists
Martin Jenek in my laboratory and
Christoph choynski and Emmanuel's Levin
these guys figured out that casts 9 is
an amazing enzyme shown in the blue sort
of blobby structure here that holds on
to DNA this molecule at the top at a
position that matches the 20 nucleotides
of of this part of the RNA sequence that
comes from the CRISPR array this
molecule right here importantly this
doesn't work this chemistry doesn't work
unless this enzyme has a second RNA
present in the complex called tracer
which is the red molecule and are a type
of RNA that is found in these bacteria
it's actually important for producing
the functional units of RNA from the
CRISPR array but we figured out that it
actually sticks around by base pairing
interactions and forms a binding site
sort of a handle for the caste 9 protein
to hold on to when the protein holds on
to these two RNAs it's it's able to
carry out the chemistry shown here by
opening up the DNA at the position
matching these 20 letters of the RNA and
generating a double-stranded break by
two chemical active sites in the enzyme
that cut to the two strands of the DNA
so it's not cutting it randomly it's
cutting it at this very precise position
that's marked by the RNA molecule and
furthermore Martin genic in my lab was
you know studying very good biochemist
he was figuring out what what parts of
this RNA molecule and this RNA molecule
are essential for this chemistry to
happen
and that led to a realization that we
could actually link together the two
separate RNAs into what we call a single
guide RNA and RNA that would have both
the targeting information and the handle
forecast binding in the same piece of
RNA and once we did that experiments and
show that this RNA could then be
designed with a desired sequence here
that would direct this protein to cut
any DNA sequence of interest this was
for us I think really the moment kind of
that proverbial moment when we realized
that a project that had started as a
fundamental research project that was
curiosity driven could you know had
really sort of led us to an
understanding of a molecular function
that could be harnessed for a very
different purpose and so when we
published that work in 2012 with a
manual we proposed this as an RNA guided
tool for gene editing so to explain how
we go from a DNA cleaver to something
that can edit DNA let me show you just a
short video that illustrates how we
envisioned this system operates inside
of a cell like our own animal or a plant
cell so here we are zooming into the
cell and in animals and plants the DNA
is inside the nucleus and not only that
it's highly compacted it's packaged the
blue DNA here is wrapping around green
histone proteins to form structures
called nucleosomes somehow this
bacterial enzyme caste 9 has to search
through that DNA and it's able to find a
single sequence in the DNA that matches
its guide RNA molecule and when that
occurs it unwinds the DNA makes a cut
and then hands off the broken ends of
the DNA to repair enzymes in these cells
and those repair enzymes are able to fix
the the broken DNA sometimes by
inserting a new piece of DNA like shown
here or sometimes by just making a very
small change to the DNA in the process
of sealing it back together and this
property of cells to be able to repair
double-stranded break
in DNA was not new to us that had been
appreciated for a long time the
challenge was how do you introduce those
double-stranded breaks at a desired
place where you might want to trigger a
change to the genomic sequence of DNA in
the cells have changed the genetic
program of the cell in that way and
that's really what the CRISPR caste 9
molecule with its RNA guide enables is
an easy way to reprogram this caste 9
protein for DNA cutting at a desired
sequence to trigger that kind of change
so so since that that 2012 publication
one of the things that my lab has been
very keen to understand is is really to
answer this fundamental question what is
the mechanism of DNA recognition so at
the sort of the simplest level we know
that this is a property of base pairing
that happens between the RNA molecule
this sequence right here and the DNA but
as I've tried to indicate in this
cartoon that ability of the RNA to
interact with the DNA requires the DNA
to be unwound so this is a DNA double
helix embedded in a complex compacted
structure in the cell and somehow this
enzyme has to find that that matching
DNA sequence and then unwind it to allow
this RNA DNA hybridization to occur so
one of the things that's emerged over
the years from our research and the
research of others that are working in
this field is that this is a protein
that undergoes a very large structural
change when it binds to RNA into DNA and
that's really one of its the fundamental
ways that it operates and I'm going to
show you one illustration of this so
this is a little movie that was made by
comparing different crystallographic
structures of the Cassadine protein in
its different functional states going
from the protein alone to a protein
bound to its guide RNA and then to a
protein that's associated with its guard
RNA guide on a matching DNA molecule
this little video is this
animation was put together by first-year
grad student in my lab van LaFrance and
so with what you're seeing here is the
crystallographic structure of casts 9
morphing to the state that the protein
assumes when it's bound to its guiding
RNA the orange molecule and so you saw
there was a very large structural change
it opens up a channel in the center of
the protein that contains the RNA guide
and when this molecule binds to a
matching sequence of DNA there's an
additional structural change in the
protein to accommodate that RNA DNA
helix and then finally the cleaver one
of these cleaving domains in the enzyme
has to actually rotate swing into place
so that it can cut the DNA it's clearly
a protein that's evolved to have these
really interesting structural states
that allow it to cut DNA only when it's
actually attached to a matching DNA
sequence it doesn't randomly cut or even
bind to DNA in the cell it really is
looking for matching DNA sites and then
and only then generating a
double-stranded DNA break can I play
that again sure I can play that again
yeah so here's it starts with the
protein alone and then this part of it
structure changing quite dramatically to
accommodate the RNA guide this molecule
right here that contains the sequence
which is in the center that has the
matching letters to DNA so it's a you
know it's a really kind of a very cool
machine that allows DNA binding by
accommodating the the rna-dna hybrid
with this additional change to the
structure and then and only then this
chemical cleaver swinging into place so
chemistry can happen and the DNA can get
cut we have lots of data that I'm not
going to show you today that really
supports this model so we've done not
only crystallography we've done electron
microscopy and we've done a lot of
experiments where we put different pairs
of chemical dyes on the surface
of the protein and watch we can actually
monitor the change in distance between
the dyes as a function of these
different conformational States so it's
really an interesting system for the
kind of studies that one can do and and
also to look at how this chemical this
conformational change affects the
function of this enzyme in a gene
editing context and this is just showing
you that more recently it's we've been
able to actually trap this protein on a
double strand a true sort of double
stranded DNA substrate with its bound
guide and this is a again a little movie
that shows zooming into the structure
you can see the rna-dna hybrid there the
blue and orange molecule in the center
and this is showing you how both strands
of the DNA are accommodated so the DNA
is literally held open by the protein
and then you can see the RNA kind of you
know snaking through the structure of
the protein it's really kind of an
integral part of this protein this piece
of RNA and then the chemical cleaver in
the enzyme here in this image in green
that then has to rotate into place so
that it can actually cut the DNA so it's
a really kind of a very interesting
little machine and one thing just to
keep in mind is that this DNA unwinding
happens without any external energy
source so I like to show this little
model of a you know a masseuse right and
sort of coaching coaxing the DNA strands
apart and Castine does this without
hydrolyzing ATP or GTP which are the
typical molecules that are coupled to
energetic changes in in cells this
doesn't happen with this enzyme somehow
it's coaxing the strands apart without
without an external source of energy and
we think that largely this is due to
favourable thermodynamics so for those
of you that study nucleic acid structure
you might know that when you have two
strands of DNA that are hybridized you
have a helix of DNA that's actually less
stable then when we have a strand of RNA
that's hybridized to DNA and that's even
less stable than we when we have two
strands of RNA that are hybridized to
each other just in a sort of an
energetic sense so this is an end
that takes advantage of that because
we're swapping a DNA DNA hybridization
for an rna-dna hybrid that's actually
more stable the trick is for this enzyme
to get that annealing process started
between the RNA guide and the DNA once
it gets going we think it slips up as
long as there is base pairing
complementarity that then triggers the
structural change in the enzyme that
leads to DNA cutting so that's that's
sort of what we've been doing
mechanistically and and one of the
things that has happened over the last
few years as my sort of many of members
of my lab been working on the mechanism
of caste 9 is that you know we've
increasingly gotten really excited about
the opportunities to use that
mechanistic understanding to a tackle
one of the big challenges going forward
with gene editing which was alluded to
in the introduction which is the
opportunity to use gene editing to
actually cure genetic disease it's kind
of an amazing thing to think that we're
really on the threshold of a technology
that's going to enable that making a
change to the DNA not not having to
treat somebody chronically with small
molecules or pills they have to take for
their whole life to treat a disease but
actually to treat it at its source by
correcting the code in the DNA and how
would one actually do that and I think
there are three sort of big challenges
when we think about this going forward
and lots of lots of other challenges too
but these are three of the big ones one
is delivery how do we actually get these
gene editing molecules into the cells
where they would need to be active to
create a cure for disease secondly how
do we control the way the DNA repair
happens because as I told you the
Cassadine protein is a great chemical
cleaver of DNA that's programmable but
the editing actually happens after that
it happens in the cell with natural
machinery in the cell so how do we
understand that well enough that we can
really control exactly how that editing
is happening in every single cell we're
not there yet but it's the field is
definitely moving in that direction and
then finally there's a number of ethical
challenges that come up with editing
especially for particular kinds of app
patience and I'm gonna just talk about
that briefly at the at the end of the
top but I wanted to share with you a few
slides that just illustrate some of the
work that's going on in my own lab that
is very I couldn't have imagined doing
this even a few years ago but it's just
been so exciting to have the opportunity
to work with colleagues on ways that we
might address neurological disease one
of the arguably most challenging kinds
of applications of gene editing because
of the challenge of getting these gene
editing complexes into the brain so this
is just a slide that shows that and I
think you're familiar here with the
concept that a number of neurological
disorders actually originate or at least
are exacerbated by by the sequence of
DNA that that are in in the cells and
this is just showing that Parkinson's
Alzheimer's Huntington's and ALS are all
diseases where we know some of the of
the genetic causes and in some cases
like in the case of Huntington's which
is a fortunately fairly rare disorder
but that has been studied for a long
time we actually know exactly where
mutations occur in one gene that are
responsible for this neurological
disorder that patients will get often
when they're in their 20s to 40s it's a
degenerative disease and there's no
treatment for it right now so it's a
terrible thing when families know they
have this trait in their family you know
it's a really a horrifying thing to know
that you might have this and if you have
this gene that you have a predisposition
to getting this disorder and there's
really nothing that can be done for it
except palliative kinds of care so so a
few years back Brett Stoll came to my
laboratory as a postdoctoral fellow who
was interested in asking the question
whether we could really develop the
CRISPR cast line technology in ways that
would eventually allow treatment or even
cure of disorders like Huntington's and
and so when he came to the lab we
started thinking about this question of
delivery and at the time there were sort
of several ways that people had been
working on delivering the
Tass 9rn a complex into cells and and
I'm just going to show you some of them
here so one way is to do it by encoding
the Cassadine protein and its guide RNA
in a DNA molecule so that DNA goes into
the cell and then it gets copied into
RNA and the RNA gets translated into
protein and it assembles with a piece of
guide RNA that's also encoded here and
then you get editing a second way is to
use a virus to introduce the the encoded
sequence the sequence encodes caste line
in its guide RNA into cells you can also
use direct delivery of messenger RNA
that encodes the protein and this can be
done by encapsulating it into lipid
nanoparticles or other kinds of
nanoparticles so these are all ways that
had been delivery methods that have been
used for other kinds of molecules and
could be adapted quickly for for
delivery of caste line but it's
biochemists we started wondering whether
we might actually be able to think of a
different way of doing the delivery that
might have certain advantages and the
idea was could we actually use a non
genetically encoded form of caste 9 main
namely doing what we do is biochemists
in the lab which is taking our purified
caste 9 protein assembling it with guide
RNAs that would direct it to the
huntingtin gene and delivering that
somehow directly into cells and in a an
important advantage of this kind of
strategy when you have a non genetically
encoded delivery mechanism is that you
don't have to worry about this editing
molecule hanging around in cells for a
long time because the protein has a very
short lifetime about 24 hours in cells
that means that it goes in does its
business generating a cut that gets
repaired and then that chemical cleaver
is degraded so we don't have to worry
about it hanging around for a long time
and potentially leading to unintended
cuts in the DNA that would generate
undesired edits potentially so with that
idea in mind
Bret started to do experiments to ask
whether this approach would actually
work and so the idea was to take
purified Cassadine protein assemble it
with guide RNA in vitro that means just
in
taking these purified molecules and
mixing them together and then adding
them to cells and we were doing this
initially just in in cultured cells and
he had another I thought very very good
idea he took advantage of cells that had
been made in mice that have been
engineered in they're having their
genome a piece of DNA that encodes a red
protein called tomato and when this
tomato protein with the gene for the the
red protein is initially encoded in such
a way that it's turned off so it doesn't
get made but he designed editing
complexes that would edit the DNA
leading to a an activation of this
tomato gene an expression of the red
protein which turns the cells red so as
a very idea was to use that strategy to
easily visually detect cells that had
been edited so this is just showing
again a cartoon of how the idea for
doing this where you have these cast
line proteins that can edit the DNA
ahead of the cat of the tomato gene
turning it on and turnin the cells red
and so so that idea let me just show you
what this actually looks like so if you
do this in cells that are growing in a
dish in the lab you can actually
introduce that protein RNA complex just
by very gentle disruption of the cell
membranes these complexes go in and we
were very gratified to see that the more
of this RNA protein complex or RMP that
we added to the sample these cells the
more red cells were observed and you can
actually quantify that you can separate
the red cells from the non red cells and
you can figure out roughly how many
cells have gotten edited and we could
get a very nice kind of dose response
here the more of this editor we added to
the cells the more cells got edited so
it's fine in the lab but how would you
actually do this what if you wanted to
be able to do that kind of editing in
cells of a brain and you can't you can't
easily how are you gonna disrupt the
brain cell membranes and you probably
wouldn't want to do that anyway and so
how do you how do you get this in and so
another idea that bread had this was
really based on some work a guy named
Carlos vargas who was doing did a lot of
the pioneering work on earlier
technologies for gene editing molecules
called zinc finger nucleases and the
idea that Barbara slab had had presented
and we adapted it here was to introduce
on to the Cassadine protein sequences of
protein that would be cell penetrating
so these are charged little pieces of
protein that have the ability to
penetrate cell membranes and so Brett
generated a series of these protein cast
line complexes with different numbers of
these cell penetrating peptides on the
surface and and then he was able to show
that when you mix cells drawing in a
dish with these proteins if you have no
penetrating peptides on the protein we
got no editing without any kind of
artificial disruption of the cell
membranes but if we had these
penetrating peptides on the protein now
we saw red cells so we could and we
could quantify this and this is just
showing that the more of these
penetrating peptides were on the cell
surface of Casner and the more editing
we saw and we could actually quantify
that further and I won't drag you
through this this gel analysis in detail
but this was just a way of really
quantifying how much change to the DNA
had actually occurred in us in a given
number of cells by doing using a system
of that could actually allow us to
detect edited DNA and separate it from
non edited DNA and this is just showing
that we could test the activity of these
proteins that have the penetrating
peptides on the surface and show that
they behaved exactly the same in terms
of their chemistry as the non modified
protein and then I really just want to
show you this result here so this is now
fast-forwarding so we said ok we have
modified cassadine proteins that can get
into cells what happens if we actually
inject these into an animal brain and so
here we're using this TD tomato reporter
Mouse and that just means that we have
now a whole Mouse that has in its genome
this tomato gene
again downstream of a DNA sequence that
gets edited by the caste line complexes
that we're making and to deliver it we
have a tiny tiny needle that gets
inserted into the skull and it actually
goes in to a part of the brain where we
can eject a very small volume of these
modified protein cast line RNA complexes
and then observe the amount of editing
by simply sectioning the brain at
different times after this injection to
see how many cells turn red and as you
can see here on the right hand side we
were really gratified to see that we
could see these fairly large volumes of
cells that get edited around in sort of
a volume around the site of injection
we've now done a lot of this kind of
work with this mouse model and also now
increasingly with an actual mouse model
of Huntington's disease and we're very
excited to to find that we can edit
about 30% of the cells in a given volume
it's really depends on the the amount of
the Cassadine protein that we inject and
furthermore we're now in the process
which kind of midstream in doing
experiments with this Huntington's model
a mouse model to figure out if we can
actually see a therapeutic benefit to
the animals and we were excited to you
know we think we are and so that we
think this is actually going to be a
strategy that's going to be really very
exciting to develop going forward and I
want to share one other observation with
you and that is that some very
interesting kind of fundamental biology
came out of this because what we found
and again I'm not going to drag you
through all of these panels here but
this is an experiment that we did to
look at so again we we can tell when
cells have been edited by looking at
when they turn red and then we can also
stain them with different antibodies
that tell us what type of cell it was
whether it whether it was a particular
type of neuron or some other type of
cell based on the proteins that are on
the surface that these antibodies will
bind to and these experiments when we do
them showed us that well we get very
nice editing in different kinds of
neurons we saw no editing and a
different type of cell called astrocytes
and and that's very interesting because
these cells are all you know the right
so they're in very close proximity
and so there's something really
different about the way these cells we
think uptake the caffeine protein and
the way they might respond to this DNA
cutter something that we're following up
right now to just understand
fundamentally what's distinct about
these different cell types and the way
they respond to editing and I'm just
gonna in the last couple of minutes I
just want to say a little bit about what
I call responsible progress so this is a
slide that just illustrates the large
number of organisms that have now been
edited using CRISPR cast line and it's
all sorts of things right it's a animals
plants fungi you know animals that have
been or organisms that have been
intractable in the past to genetic
manipulation are now can be edited and
studied at a very detailed level using
gene editing so it's been really really
exciting it's just the pace of research
over the last few years has increased
just tremendously with the you know this
technology coupled with other
technologies for imaging and DNA
sequence analysis that have been coming
online and and this has also led to some
really interesting applications and I'm
just going to share a couple with you
one is the possibilities of using CRISPR
cast nine and in agriculture and this
was a paper that was published last
summer from a academic labs a clippin at
Cold Spring Harbor labs that was able to
use cast nine to
tomato plants to be able to carry a much
heavier yield of tomatoes and I'm a
tomato farmer so I was very excited
disease but I think it's really a
harbinger of what's coming it really
shows that in the future and maybe the
not distant future we're going to see
agricultural products plants but also
animals that will have precision gene
editing carried out that lead to traits
that are desirable and rather than
having to spend years of time breeding
in the laboratory to get to something
like this and in the process introducing
who knows what random mutations in the
DNA you can instead go in with a very
precise tool make one tweak and have a
result like this I think it's a really
just gives you it sort of it's an
exciting sort of time and in biology for
that reason and I also want to just say
a couple of words about germline editing
so the type of editing that I was
talking about with Huntington's disease
and treating diseases like that involves
somatic cell editing making DNA changes
that are not heritable but what about
editing the germline what if we were to
edit eggs or sperm or embryos where the
resulting DNA changes become part of the
whole organism and are then passed on to
future generations and this became you
know this is something that became
possible very quickly with CRISPR
Castine and mice and rats and other
kinds of organisms in early 2014 it was
done in monkeys where it was possible to
make a precise change to the DNA in
monkey embryos and have resulting
monkeys that were normal except they had
this one little change to their DNA and
this immediately made people start
asking could this happen in humans and
this was actually a cover of The
Economist magazine of all things you
know already two years ago under the
banner editing humanity and people
thinking about designer babies and you
know how soon were we gonna see designer
babies and and so in the course of all
of this I I really realized that you
know as a person who was kind of you
know they're at the genesis of this this
technology that I really needed to be
involved in that public discussion about
how we would proceed to use this and
hopefully to use it in a responsible
fashion and so that has led to a large
number of meetings and and and reports
that have been generated but I wanted to
mention one in particular which is the
the report on human genome editing
published just about a year ago by the
National Academies that looked very
deeply at this question of human
germline editing and make us made a set
of recommendations and I think the
interesting thing there is that the
recommendations were to proceed with
caution but not to necessarily stop and
I think what we've seen just in the last
few months in fact is that groups are
moving ahead with sort of testing the
validity and the and the the technical
aspects of editing in embryos and the
jury's out we don't really understand
fully what how these technologies are
going to work yet in embryos but I think
it's a technology that's coming and it
really does I think you know illustrate
to all of us that this is something that
is not science fiction
anymore right we're really it's really
it's a technology that's really almost
here and we have to be thinking about
the implications and how we would feel
about this being used in in vitro
fertilization clinics for example and I
just want to call to your attention that
one of the organizations that I've been
involved with in my my home town is
called the innovative genomics Institute
this was founded by me and some
colleagues a few years back it's a
Berkeley UCSF academic partnership and
we do not only research and sort of
resource that make resources available
we also do a lot of work on the ethics
and societal implications of gene
editing and I encourage you if you're
interested to check us out on the web
and we have a blog and we do we try to
do a lot of outreach to roofs we do a
lot of work with high school teachers
now to kind of help them talk to their
students and teach them about gene
editing but wait we're making a CRISPR
kit that's going to be made available
through add gene org for example that
will be for teaching kids about how gene
editing works and that's it I just want
to say thank you to my lab a huge thanks
to an incredible group of people that
are have become highly independent as
I'm off doing events you know they are
back in the lab working away and it's
just been an incredible honor and
pleasure to work with these folks over
the years and and then of course we have
been blessed with incredible academic
collaborators I've listed some of them
here but I really want to highlight
Immanuel sharp and TA in particular who
was the scientist who really was our
partner in doing all of this work on
CRISPR Castine and of course we couldn't
do anything without funding and we're
very grateful for these agencies and and
I think I like to always give a special
shout out to the National Science
Foundation that gave me a very small but
critical grant in the early days of
CRISPR in my lab that helped us get
started on this whole wild adventure and
thank you very much
[Applause]
we have some time for questions hello
so one of the most remarkable things
about this search and and cleave
mechanism is just how big the search
space is so can you say something about
how how long it takes and how what sort
of error rate or redundancy there is I
mean you know in the human genome say
there's three billion nucleotides and
that's a lot of searching what's the
sort of kinetics of such an approach for
the cell yeah it's a great question and
I don't I don't really have a great
answer for you we've done some work with
live cell imaging where you can
fluorescently label cast 9 and then
watch its kinetic behavior inside the
nucleus of a living cell we've done this
in Mouse cells and what those
experiments show is that it's a protein
that has really rapid kinetics so it's
search it's certainly moving around the
DNA very quickly it's able to get into
even really highly compacted parts of
the genome with apparent kinetic ease we
don't know exactly how that operates at
a molecular level but we haven't been
able to really calculate the time it
takes you know you'd love to know that
right like how long does it take one
molecule of cassadine to find a target
site in the human genome for example and
it's been really hard to actually
calculate that because we don't really
know how many molecules are in the
nucleus right so when we do an
experiment like what I described with
the the brain cell Nerone neuron
neuronal cell editing if we do that in a
dish where we add the protein to the
cells we see evidence for editing within
about two hours of adding the cast line
to the cells so that sounds like wow
that's pretty fast but what we don't
know is how many molecules actually got
into the cell nucleus that are doing
that searching and likewise we don't
really know what the kinetics are of
interacting with off targets so sort of
you know closely matched but not
perfectly matched DNA sequences except
to say that there's a lot of evidence
now from many labs that there's a lot of
that going on but most of the time those
sites don't get cut so there's a
distinction between cast 9 binding
cast line cutting so my guess is you
probably have to have a fair number of
cast nine molecules in the nucleus
because a lot of them may get hung up at
places in the DNA where they're not
actually making a cut actually that was
very closely related to my question it
was more about well the number of
molecules but how many pieces of RNA do
you think cast nine has to bump into
before it finds the right one and then
go find its target area on the DNA how
many pieces of RNA or DNA yeah like I
said my question was very similar to
hers yeah so so once it once it finds
its RNA guide right than that that
complex seems to be very high affinity
it doesn't really fall apart until it
gets you know degraded so that's a very
tight interaction but the binding then
then searching and cutting DNA seems to
have different kinetics it's really
rapidly binding and releasing DNA and
that's probably essential for its search
mechanism and I didn't I didn't mention
this but we have data showing that it
doesn't bind and slide along DNA to find
a target site rather it's binding and
releasing DNA very quickly and that's
actually probably a good thing because I
think if it were a process of enzyme
that could bind and slide it would
probably immediately get stuck and sort
of hung up in chromatin for example but
that doesn't happen I think because of
this rapid release kind of action I see
I was really curious whether you thought
it was existing in some sort of
scaffolding complex but sounds like not
so with the speed of things that's what
we think okay thank you
keep this one going did you say at the
beginning that purified DNA purified
caste 9 with the guy no problem opening
that's right okay yeah hi thank you very
much great talk and thanks for making
the trip to CMU what are the
implications for the the epigenome it
all of this I mean I'm sitting here
thinking well does it matter and does
you know the epigenome wraps around the
DNA and controls it and you can activate
a DNA by for example methylation loss
but how did how does this alt have you
thought about that how it ties together
yeah so so she's asking about the
epigenome meaning DNA that's been
chemically methylated for example and
and ways that the cell controls the
expression of genes without actually
modifying the actual DNA sequence and
you know the interesting thing about
caste 9 is that it's a it's a great
platform for any kind of DNA
manipulation site-specific manipulation
and you know there's been a number of
nice papers on this not from us from
from many others there's a beautiful
paper that just came out and sell from
Rudolf jaenisch for example where he
showed that you could do really nice
epigenetic modification of the genome in
a targeted fashion using a modified
version of caste 9 so I think that opens
the door to yet another whole
interesting realm of biology where we
can really explore how much epigenetic
changes are controlling things and you
know in the end I wonder if that might
actually be a better way to do clinical
sort of applications because you don't
have to worry about DNA recombination
and things like that
due to cutting or cancer exactly so
right thinking about cell proliferation
right we have time for one more question
brief question so I've been looking and
it seems that most of the cast proteins
that are in use for gene editing are
from human pathogens like a
Staphylococcus in years
but from what I know it was originally
discovered in archaea is there a reason
that the the human pathogens are in use
more than the other versions so crazily
enough up until very recent some very
recent work that we did with Jill
Banfield there were no examples of cast
line in any archaea so there's lots and
lots of CRISPR systems in archaea but no
no cast lines
none of this type right so they're
they're mostly only in bacteria and
furthermore for reasons that are not
entirely understood yet the ones that
have been the most effective for gene
editing that at least the ones have been
tested for that so far have been those
coming from these pathogenic bacteria
and I don't I can't explain why that is
but that's just that's the observation
so you might be bringing this up because
there was recent work posted on a
preprint server the bio archive that
showed that people have some people at
least have an Tabo antibodies to these
cast line proteins because maybe they've
been exposed to those bacteria over
there the you know they're a lifetime
and nobody knows yet if those levels of
antibodies will you know interfere with
with cast 9 but even if they did I would
argue that I think there's lots of other
cast lines in nature that are yet to be
tested for this that could be useful and
also there's just a huge amount of going
on right now in you know various kinds
of bioengineering laboratories that are
engineering these proteins in different
ways so I think that's not likely to be
a showstopper for this I hope that you
will be able to stay for the reception
which is easy to find right in this room
after we thank dr. Daoud into one more
time for a spectacular time thank you
very much
[Music]
[Applause]